today for the first time I'm going to
look through an exam that I didn't
actually do myself as part of my degree
specifically I'm going to have a look at
financial mathematics also sort of
classed as quantitative finance now this
probably is going to have enough
mathematics in it for me to recognize
but I've never really seen it in the
financial context before so I thought it
would be interesting to have a look
through this exam another reason why I'm
interested in this finance exam is
because I know that a lot of people that
go on to specialise in maths and physics
and get PhDs in those fields end up
working in finance companies without I
guess direct academic training and
finance and I'm interested to see what
is it about the math and physics skills
that the finance companies think I guess
so relevant and why would they hire
people with a PhD in physics to come and
work for Wall Street initially when I
heard that I thought it may be that's
quite a rare thing to happen but
actually you can read all about the
physics of Wall Street and in fact
current economic theory and trading is
based a lot upon fundamental equations
and practices that come from research
physics and mathematics I've seen a few
of these financial recruiting firms
myself as a PhD student in physics I've
received emails from these companies
saying things like you know come and
work for us in finance it doesn't matter
that you don't have finance training you
can pick up all the necessary knowledge
about assets and about stocks and all
that on the job what we're looking for
are people with really good skills in
dealing with data finding trends and
data and a bit of coding as well so I'm
sort of curious to see I guess this
financial mathematics exam might show me
what some of these skills are that would
need to be picked up on the job but it
really I'm just interested to see as
someone with a background in math
if I can even tackle this at all there
will be a link in the description for
you to download this exam so you can
read along with me there's no solutions
provided but I will put links to where a
lot of the questions have come from and
let's have a look so this exam is in
three sections that are all kind of
similar but section one here is
probability theory and stochastic
process so probability sort of makes
sense to have in a finance exam because
financial markets are full of
uncertainty and stochastic process what
that refers to is I guess random
processes or at least seemingly random
processes there are actually a lot of
stochastic processes in science in all
fields of science physics chemistry
neuroscience computer science it's yeah
the idea of having something that seems
around and pops up more often than you
might think
so in a way learning stochastic
processes and how to deal with them is
not just going to help you in finance
but in a lot of fields of science first
we have a question about the
distributions of random variables in
this case we have Poisson distribution
and that's something that I have
encountered before out of the context of
finance it can be used for all sorts of
things most commonly the example is
working out how many customers you might
expect in a certain amount of time given
some averages that you already know
cushion 1a is actually compute the
moment generating function of X and well
that requires knowing what a moment
generating function is but I did Google
that and it seems to be a way that
simplifies finding the mean and variance
christian b is talking about Markov
processes and a markov process is also
something that could appear not just in
finance but in all kinds of science and
it means that essentially there is no
memory for a system so something is a
mark
process you should be able to predict
its future from just its present state
and having any memory or history about
the system isn't going to help you it's
it's I guess random and just that it
doesn't depend on past events part a of
this question says simple random walk
and actually that's a phrase that I
recognize from things like astrophysics
and I think a random walk just refers to
the stochastic or random process that
could apply to a gas molecule bumping
around or to even a foraging animal it's
essentially just a particle that moves
in random directions until it eventually
finds what it's looking for
so some of these terms already like I
recognize from physics and math but you
know some of the rest of this question I
wouldn't know how to do it's it's using
these terms in a context that's
unfamiliar to me questions see is asking
about a Markov chain and from what I
understand a Markov chain contains a set
of states and a matrix containing the
probabilities of transitioning from one
state to another the state of the chain
at any time is a random variable just
like everything else on this page
section 2 deals with volatility modeling
and from what I can tell volatility in
this sense refers to an annual standard
deviation of the change in price or
value of a financial security I think
the volatility is essentially a way that
you can estimate a market risk and the
question on this page it's just one
question with many parts
I think concerns that idea probably the
one word over who knows on this question
is Brownian motion now Brownian motion I
thought was a purely physics idea it's I
guess the random movement of microscopic
particles in a fluid whether it's air or
water
caused by the bombardment of molecules
in the medium that it's in I think
there's a famous experiment where pollen
grains were dropped into water and you
could see them bouncing around as if
they were alive but it was found that no
the pollen grains are not alive they are
just being bombarded by the molecules in
the water and it's actually one of mine
Stein's famous papers that discussed
these ideas of Brownian motion so it's
interesting to see it use here in terms
of Finance and just looking at this exam
it actually comes up a few times so I
think modeling things randomly just like
you would in Brownian motion is actually
quite important here I don't recognize
the context of a lot of the math and the
questions on this page but yes they seem
to be doing things with variants
distribution so it looks like this
question is mainly about statistics just
in a context that's unfamiliar to me as
a math major
the final section here stochastic
calculus and differential equations so
like I said stochastic refers to random
variables so stochastic calculus would
be the way that you model the random
motion of I guess in finance asset
prices and the difference between
stochastic calculus and normal calculus
is that stochastic calculus allows the
derivative to have a random component
determined by Brownian motion and for a
stochastic differential equation say for
the asset price you'd be able to solve
that to get a path of the stock price
the questions here are dealing a lot
with integrals I see one familiar friend
of mine the phrase integration by parts
so that's used a lot in physics in math
in general so nice to see it being used
here as well I've proved integration by
parts many times just not in the context
of this stochastic calculus relating to
finance so I can see that some of the
schools are transfer
but yeah it does look a bit unfamiliar
to me at this point one way to get a
feel for studying math or finance at
university is to look at exams like this
but a much better way is to actually
work through some exercises on the
subject and put your knowledge to the
test on brilliant org you can develop
your mathematical skills through courses
including one on math for quantitative
finance brilliant guides you through a
problem by breaking it down into its
component pieces helping you understand
how they relate to each other and then
building back up to a conclusion
brilliant also actually can help you
apply for top firms in the industry and
give you exposure to career
opportunities in finance if you are
thinking about developing your math
skills to propel your career then go to
brilliant org slash Tibby's and sign up
for free in addition the first 200
people that go to that link will get 20%
off an annual premium subscription
Thanks brilliant for sponsoring this
video and thank you for watching